hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to unforgiving a
northern him Oh ladies over there we
need to go this way so we got the
problem because this lady will not leave
us alone but that's ok because we just
need to find the him that we need to
know to be able to do what we need to do
now there was something at the bell
tower and I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to get to the bell tower I don't
even know if there's a way to hide from
this lady I think that maybe if I crouch
and don't sprint everywhere I go and
don't jump and go oh I think I might be
able to get away from this lady but I
don't think that's gonna take place here
anytime soon so we need to get to the
bell tower and we need to look
[Music]
what did what what what did you give
everything for I mean it seems obviously
that you gave up your freedom and
probably your life considering you're a
tree now which is nice I guess oh oh
this is what I needed the Jung ah now I
know why I did those things did I get a
new tune I guess I did huh
oh hey hey hey hey hey hey hey all right
well that's a problem okay well I run
this way now all right okay lady you can
see calm down there it's not that big
deal I am pretty cool and I know very
handsome but you can stay away for at
least a little bit and control yourself
because I need to get this all taken
care of
and I need to go where the hell did I go
how did I get you I think I need to go
past the wall maybe a little bit just
need to tuck behind the wall and then I
need to go that way I see her over there
but she's not don't talk about telly
sitting my notes yeah but I got another
melody and I think that might be what we
needed to be able to get across this
river because if it is then that means
we're gonna be able to progress if it's
not then it means we're gonna die on the
docks because the lady is gonna stab us
in the butt Tyagi need to go over to
Fire Mountain or hopefully there are a
few less trolls Oh someone was
mentioning by the way someone was
mentioning that there was another game
that seemed to be similar to this one
that I played a demo of a long time ago
who's where you started the game staring
up at a moon and you went into a cave
and you almost died - what looked like a
troll and not 100% sure about that but
it did happen
so all right do I play this here do I
play the song of your people I heard
something I don't know what I heard
[Music]
okay cool all right cool that oh okay
all right oh yeah that's right that's
bad I remember that oh yeah okay all
right well ah I remember how that turns
us into trees in all such oh I got a
plank of wood if I didn't know about
that I would have gotten the plank of
wood from the woods I was
you know I was in woods or the wooded
area the woody woods all right fine
away I go then Sarah Nora yah
it's a born Fuji goodbye ray see ya
right off the Fire Mountain I go goes
just match ain't doing me no good better
burn my fingernail off a little bit more
well this is a conundrum because now I
got a bite on my arm and if I Oh nope
there is not there oh wait no he's on
the other side of something I don't know
it's there what was that sound careful
now don't fall in the water now nope
that's oh no it's that thing from Game
of Thrones
no it's not good father
where'd the Fire Mountain go wait hang
on take is it that game where I'm in a
raft in the middle of the ocean because
that's work that's where I went crazy I
don't want to go crazy here in this land
of trolls and mythical creatures but oh
I hate this oh hi okay hey look I got
something do you want to play a
doodle-doo
I don't do it with you you like my
doodles
[Laughter]
[Music]
what okay all right thank you thank you
very much thank you very much thank you
very much very much thank you to you the
thanking that I am doing you thank you
very much thank you very much yeah
alrighty then
well that is a conundrum that I am
currently enduring so to be able to cure
myself I got a trust a gremlin creature
that wants my harp of magical
proportions but then again I don't have
a lot of attachment to the art I can
touch I kind of don't give a in
this endeavor because I just don't want
to bother with anybody here so you know
it is the way that it is a year
hello what words of wisdom do you have
for me well you got a silly face no
you've got too soon
you got silly face ooh what's on your
shoulder all right a bite mark yep
that's what I suspected you bites you
get tree
[Music]
okay so don't trust him well I mean it
seems like I might be powerless to his
will so maybe I should just give it to
him in usher the end of the world you
think maybe that's probably a good idea
what do we have here
for bond Ellison oh there we go the
curse when she has given her sharp kiss
the poison spreads into the bloodstream
in the brats two soul twisting one's
bones so they sink into the earth at
last you transform into an unholy tree
forget who you are and become hers
forever well that would have been good
to know beforehand
let me play my magical harp here boink
[Music]
uh-huh what did that do huh
what did that do I wonder what did that
do what did you do huh can you tell me I
would like to know because you know it's
kind of important for this whole
endeavor that I'm out of going here it's
adventure I don't really know why I'm
here
why I rip the tongue out of my brother's
mouth and his eyeball before I even knew
I needed them but you know it is what it
is all right anyway that burnt hello
tree do you have something to say to me
tree oh nice hello no nothing okay all
right thank you I don't know what these
are for I'm collecting like these poster
things from all around the island and
they have no meaning to me thus far but
they've gotta be for something like to
know something more about the history or
the origin of all this there's got to be
a deeper meaning to all the things that
I'm seeing in front of me right here but
I just don't know what they are that's
the weirdest thing about it there's
something here but I don't see hello
hello hi nobody was it Oh
[Music]
okay I don't want to slither through
your dark passages that sounds patently
unpleasant do I need to play my harp
here for this tune okay well I got those
so those are on the gates if the gates
gonna open for me now also I saw ya you
hi little gremlin creature what is with
you you've got a mouth on you and I
don't like that you're not a tree you're
just a just a stone horror don't like it
okay alright I think I understand
Oh down F alright I got it down F that
sue salut Y and down F boy this harp
sure came in handy okay oh boy more is
this is gonna be ring-around-the-rosy
and me finding the cymbals and playing
I'm a nice jaunty tune and then I'm
gonna be able to go forward in life is
that the only thing that I'm waiting for
you hey who's creaking out there you
don't need to be creaking up I'll buy me
no no no no that's unnecessary I hear
things which I did not enjoy oh this is
bad hello but the Dada Dada who's got a
machine gun huh
you better be using her on that big a
stroll
oh hello I found you I found you okay
hurry up please
a little faster on the the withdrawal of
the harp thunk-thunk who's
Duncan who's Tonka Lunken whose thumb ah
who's got that machine got into who's
not killing that goddamn troll oh my god
took control of the machine gun goddamn
royally bone of that is the case okay
No Wow hello friend that was right there
that probably saw me Wow didgeridoo
oh boy I don't like this the ambience is
mixing into the reality and I don't like
it
nope
don't like that nope yep yep nothing
like will do not like I see it I see it
I've got I spy on it I'm playing a big
old game I spy and I see it yeah I spy
with my little eye a red circular bottle
over there I'm gonna play a harp into I
could sing into it if it wants oh that's
oh that's no good okay I don't know if
this is not gonna oh I don't know not
this no no all the didgeridoo man oh
this is a mistake okay alright where are
you where are you troll didgeridoo man
there you are why do they have to be
naked you know at least the Hulk had the
common courtesy to keep his pants on I
do I gotta play one final tune oh I do
oh good up f something down F I don't
know what it was but I don't think it's
gonna be good for me
okay alright up F Oh up F diamond down F
diamond P okay I got it
oh the curious little scamp ain't ya oh
no no how-how-how no no no no no I was
free and fun and happy troll please I
don't taste good I don't want you to be
inside of you okay are we good no I hear
it I think it's still got a bead on me
oh hi well oh that's a problem
hello well no oh whoa that's not good
that's not good ah that's not good I was
totally fine oh yeah okay we're fine
we're fine we're fine
okay okay up F diamond down F diamond P
okay that's what it is and that's why
I'm gonna do okay I got it
I got I got come on hurry hurry up f
Dimond down f Dimond got it open up
you ass blasting bastard
ohyeah which way you opening cooking
never go all right we're in whirring
whirring whirring whirring okay
all right see you dude you there oh-ho
oh that oh that's horrible
oh that is that is a boat you're fast
okay from rolling on one arm you're
awfully fast mister
oh well that's problem all right I guess
someone jump right in don't care if my
imminent demise wait for me down in
there Oh forest ranger that's good do I
get a Scout badge oh good yeah okay
where am I now
check back boss I don't know if I want
to how many do I have
oh so many I am loaded up with matches
oh I am I am rich with matches okay all
right
who's down here say yes hello
Oh a whole mining operation huh
denizens of the darkness I kicked over
your tin cans run away and fear me
I am your demise okay Oh pop up pop out
good rate down daddy's crying looks like
daddy's dead I want to call it like I
see it but I think I see it like I call
it okay so I got to find more of those
bastards
what Oh God they'll punished they can
hear you they were imprisoned deep
underground the ground their souls
warped and they succumb to evil all
together in the dark their eyes withered
and they learn to listen to the whispers
of the mountain oh good terrifying
babies that can hear me screaming hey
babies hey hey you're and I
hate you how about that you like that I
didn't think so
I didn't think so ooh dad says we'll go
home soon
I don't know Desir lackeys of the Norns
diss a female a female spirit of the
dead is a slave to fate they're under
the influence of the Norns carry out
their wicked will and see to it the
threads of life are spun as the three
desire
okay then alright musical manuscript
book harp well that would have been good
to read Swedish tales yeah okay hello
who's here who is you who is you huh no
that's weird
okay but I'm not gonna question it
because I don't question anything okay
that's out of power some tells me that
screaming babies are waiting in the
darkness whatever let's keep moving I
guess let's go towards the horrible
sounds I want to go outside too bad uh
you can't you can never escape your life
is in here now and misery and torment
and the darkness oh okay and what am I
supposed to do about that thing am I
supposed to jump on that oh I see the
other thing okay that's over there I'll
come back and get that and play the harp
too it's sweetly in its ear but for now
for nada
oh she won't get us here
I remember what I have to do I'm not
gonna do it now until I have to do it I
don't want to have to do that again if
you guys saw the demo you know what I'm
talking about but if you didn't then
avert your eyes they found daddy I
wasn't allowed to look oh my god okay
though well that's sad that is that's
very sad okay
remember all spare parts are kept in
storage ah okay all right so I gotta I
gotta go to storage is what I gotta do
and also wait
I just noticed how on the on the no not
the heart but the the the match boxes is
that what I think it is it looks like a
mother holding a child in her arms and
which is awfully ironic for what I have
to do now I'll change here we go
oh ok alright ok it didn't work Wow ok
probably because I don't have any fuel I
got a down some with fuel first mmm I
don't want to that's not what I've
wanted to do I can't do anything about
it
it's the game that's making me do it so
my desire to do anything long have you
been there
hello ok see ya the cure she fell deeply
in love with a false god and his
corruption flowed through her giving him
influence over her and her powers which
he controls by his own will ok alright
good Oh ahh ok alright well that's a
thing ok
[Music]
okay well I got that one
the other ones over on the cart floating
in the middle of the area maybe I can
play to it from here
playing to you thank you this for you up
there was for you I got you nothing a
damn dick doodlee so I got to get up
there and I got to do that which means
that I got to find some sort of a fuel
because I got to go into the storage and
I gotta burn a tree alive and it's weird
cuz it's conundrum right because these
people are cursed effectively completely
cursed they may not even be alive
anymore they're existent might be
tortured forever just as a tree until
they eventually die so maybe it's a
mercy to just no no no and it's kind of
like a soma dilemma like is it really
life after everything that's happened to
them after they've been changed like
this is it a life worth living like it
might be life but is it life worth
living and that gets into moral dilemmas
that I don't want to approach in a fun
game that's supposed to be a relaxing
adventure away from the stresses of real
life okay all right well let's go
forward first no it is what it is and
we're gonna face it no matter what we do
oh look these are boxers okay good luck
it's a bunch tunnels why am I here why
am I here why did I have to come here
why did I have to be addicted why did my
brother have to kidnap me wow I got so
many flashbacks to the amnesia water
monster I hate everything about that
rock looks like a face okay we're fine
okay we're fine we're totally fine
everything's fine everything's 100% cool
great why did I do that and why did I go
there why what is with these giant piles
of magic huh what's with all them huh
uh what do I have to do with any of this
what do I have to do with any of this
why is this my responsibility why did I
go in a big circle I didn't do what I
needed
kickin up okay well that's the point of
that did I go in a big loop no yes
cloud of razor blades the not trauma is
a creature with sharp claws in an outer
most dangerous beak they can be very
dangerous specifically in large numbers
okay well Birds how are they gonna get
down here in this horrible place that I
find myself in a box of medical supplies
bags oh this is a dead end then why am I
here so this isn't where I came from so
this must be a way through to somewhere
else
whoa what are you was in here
anything good no oh secret secrets I
definitely haven't been collecting all
those but no no Casey you do that weird
thing where you say you where you get
loud and I don't like it no I like it
none I'm trying to stop currently
present late I am very injured you gonna
do that again no okay
all right though it's just a one-time
thing then I guess why why would you do
that what I've been doing in here what's
with all the light where am I going why
did I go into this hellhole I been here
before it all looks the same I just
don't know anymore
I just don't know God I just don't know
okay whatever it doesn't matter I just
got to keep going forward and hope that
a giant arm doesn't reach out one of
those things huh it's all I can hope for
because it's weird it's just sending me
in circles there's got to be a purpose
to this where am I now Bobby was allowed
to come with some tells me something bad
happened to Bobby all right
can't sleep they're looking are they now
[Music]
okay all right that would have been an
excellent opportunity for there to be
many things looking at me up above me
they who walk in between half dead and
half alive they dwell forsaken in the
deep in hidden places and the areas were
the veil between worlds and its thinnest
yeah I think I got a close encounter
with one of those slap me in the face
all right
okay labyrinths and rituals in
Scandinavia okay
all right Scandinavia you say that a
interesting predicament well I turned
that on which I'm extremely happy about
very unbelievably happy ridiculously
beyond happy about that okay all right
well I got power on all right so that's
how you want to play it huh oh that's
how you want to play it huh okay oh
don't you get it how'd you get up there
Oh how'd you how'd you get up boy oh you
better just be the one of you is if it
ain't just the one II I'm gonna be
primarily upset did you did you just
make out with someone or did you slip
into the portal I'm gonna go for it
this is where I need to go I don't know
it's too dark yeah light
I'm gonna guess go to the light seems
like the right oh well this ain't good
I'm gonna get slapped I'm gonna get
slapped imma get slapped oh my god
slapped okay I'm not slapping God if I
was in this situation if me really me
was in this situation where I had to
explore this dark and dank tunnel all by
myself I wouldn't how do how did how
would anyone have the willpower to just
keep sprinting forward into the darkness
not knowing anything especially if there
were monsters lurking around the actual
corners how would anybody nobody would
nobody wanted it nobody would be able to
go where they needed to go sprint sprint
sprint sprint sprint sprint sprint
sprint doc I'm gonna go now whoo Wow
okay don't slap me don't slap me my
dancing candle okay we're fine I think
we're fine that's a lot of Mon
inhabitant behind me I would appreciate
if you did that nun oh you knew have you
been there okay so that's bad but anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below I will continue this
very soon so thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]